-Performing
"I'm In Love With You"
From their new album
"Being Funny
In A Foreign Language,"
give it up for The 1975!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "I'm In Love With You"
begins ]
♪♪
♪ -Heartbeat ♪
♪ is comin' in so strong ♪
♪ Oh, if you don't stop ♪
♪ I'm gonna need a second one ♪
♪ Oh, there's somethin'
I've been meaning to ♪
♪ Say to you, baby ♪
♪ -Hold that thought ♪
♪ -Oh, there's somethin'
I've been meaning to ♪
♪ Say to you, baby,
but I just can't do it ♪
♪ What a call, moving in ♪
♪ I feel like I can
loosen my lips ♪
♪ -Come on so strong ♪
♪ -I can summarize it for you. ♪
♪ It's simple
and it goes like this ♪
♪ I'm in love with you ♪
♪ -I-I-I-I ♪
♪ -I'm in love with you ♪
♪ -In love with you ♪
♪ -I-I-I-I ♪
♪ -She's got a broadsheet ♪
♪ Reading down the list
of the going wrongs ♪
♪ -Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ -I'm gettin' no sleep ♪
♪ -Tossin' and turnin'
all night long, hey ♪
-Yeah!
♪ Oh, there's somewhere I've ♪
♪ -Somewhere I've ♪
♪ -Been meaning to ♪
♪ -Meaning to ♪
♪ -Take the conversation ♪
♪ -Hold that thought ♪
♪ -Oh, there's somewhere I've ♪
♪ -Somewhere I've ♪
♪ -Been meaning to ♪
♪ -Meaning to ♪
♪ -Take the conversation,
but I just can't do it ♪
♪ You show me your ♪
♪ -You show me your ♪
♪ -Black girl thing ♪
♪ -Pretending that
I know what it is ♪
♪ -I wasn't listening ♪
♪ -I apologize ♪
♪ And you meet my eyes ♪
♪ Yeah, it's simple
and it goes like this ♪
♪ I'm in love with you ♪
♪ -I-I-I-I ♪
♪ -I'm in love with you ♪
♪ -Yeah, I'm in love with you ♪
♪ -I-I-I-I ♪
-Yeah!
♪ -In love with you ♪
♪ -I-I-I-I ♪
♪ -Yeah, I'm in love with you ♪
♪ -I-I-I-I-I ♪
♪ -Well, I got it, I found it ♪
♪ I've just gotta keep it ♪
♪ "Don't... ♪
All right --
♪ ...you muppet" ♪
♪ It's not that deep,
but I've been counting ♪
♪ My blessings ♪
♪ Thinking this through
It's like, one, two, yeah ♪
♪ I'm in love with you ♪
♪ -I-I-I-I ♪
♪ -I'm in love with you ♪
♪ -I'm in love with you,
you, you, you, yeah. ♪
♪ I'm in love with you ♪
♪ -I-I-I-I ♪
-Hey!
♪ Yeah, I'm in love with you ♪
♪ -I-I-I-I ♪
♪ -I'm in love with you ♪
♪ -In love with you ♪
♪ -I-I-I-I ♪
♪ -Yeah, I'm in love with you ♪
♪ -I-I-I-I-I ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]